with so many tough stories about animal
cruelty lately it's really good to be
able to bring you this story
about owners who go above and beyond to
take care of their pets
as we continue our pet week special
reports we take you to a unique pool in
henderson that
and swim for nearly three years she's
rarely missed her weekly visit to k-9
body work and aquatics they say a
five-minute swim for dogs is about a
five-mile run
for us it is great exercise but it also
helps
ease her anxiety boo is one of hundreds
of dogs that owner kathy carr has helped
she explains the physical and mental
benefits of hydrotherapy
working in the water it's 20 times the
resistance as on land
so even though we don't have that
pressure on the joints it's also like a
bigger bang
as well being 20 times the resistance
good boy
which is why swimming is recommended for
dogs with everything from
arthritis mobility to weight issues good
boy
hugh trong's dog cliffy is here to trim
his waistline he's trying to look for
something
that was fun climate controlled because
he doesn't do well with heats in long
walks
just natural ways to help ease any
discomfort
and make their lives happy as long as
possible
good girl judy making life more
comfortable is what it's all about for
april and her super senior
judy good job this lady is 17
blind and has trouble walking but
swimming lightens the load
and lives her spirits it's really easy
to say no
she can't see all those kind of things
but we want her to end well
because she's been there for us and she
loves it
time in this heated pool loosens the
joints boosts cardio and improves heart
health
look at the swim video my dog can swim
even though they can't walk
they can still swim and it's easy to see
what it does
for boo but it can be the magical just
power water
now a lot of veterinarians suggest cars
massage and body work as part of an
entire treatment plan to help pets
either recover
or even prevent surgery